ready all right
[Music]
all right ladies and gentlemen
welcome back to your favorite podcast
[Music]
all right ron this is the singing mic
but i won't even give you this thing of
mine i just put the effects on it on
that
okay so whatever you got for me just
get it bro we ripping with griffin
we don't know what we're doing but we're
gonna have fun
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah all right i'm living with you
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right well that's how i do it i
usually hand the single mic over but you
know in these days of like
yeah i get it you know what's funny is
like you don't know
i don't know how you deal with it but
like you know sometimes it's like
different people deal with it in
different ways
yeah you know what i mean like so you
don't you don't even know who you uh you
know
you might be with somebody who's just
like straight up like
yo stay away from me and then other
people are kind of like i'm cool
you know you know so it's just
determining who it is
have you dealt with anything where
you're like okay this is one of those
yeah of course i deal with people who
come straight up try to give you
handshakes and hugs in the middle of the
pandemic before
vaccinations and it's just you just
that's the first time you know i love a
hug
yes it's a great way to feel everything
yeah yeah yeah
and but then you i'd be like no you know
what's going on right now
so you you then have you've had a
healthy fear
of the virus from the beginning uh i'd
say not from the beginning
in the very beginning i was like you
know what's going on with this this
ain't even gonna get over here
yeah i'm gonna keep doing shows i know
we were in the comedy store hallway like
yeah they gonna come here
comedy can never stop
cut to a year later we're like oh [ __ ]
i'm doing shows in the drive-through
yeah doing
shows at the parking lot of the magic
castle yeah
at the foot of magicians yeah
so so then at what point did you go oh i
better start
like this is like like where you took it
like hey don't come near me or
you know like what level were you were
you at like 10 of like you were
you know hypochondriac or like zero like
where were you in there i was a solid
six
seven i'd say where i was like i'm not
going out
i'm staying at home as long as i can
afford to stay home if i had to go out i
would but i was like as long as i could
stay home i can
i didn't see anybody just me and my wife
and my son we just staying home that's
it we didn't
you know didn't see my mom didn't see
anybody just kept it low-key
didn't go do anything just kept doing
voiceovers that was it
yeah good for you man by the way i
really enjoyed harley quinn
um ron was the shark
what's the character killer shark or
what was it
he's okay he's a king or the king shark
yeah he's the king of the sharks
wait don't get an attitude like
it was the shark okay like this it's not
like there was like 10 sharks in there
and
and
and you like you you need me to
distinguish between the sharks like yo
yo i know common shark
it was the only [ __ ] shark in
the thing
[Laughter]
how dare you get insulted
unbelievable excuse me you know what
this is like this is like when you're
hosting a show
and somebody give you their credits
can you say like these 17 things when
you bring me up that's the words
yeah that's what you just did to me um
but yeah it was well
i don't feel the same i know i'm just
i'm exaggerating for the podcast
so yes you did voiceovers i mean i know
what you're saying like for me you know
what i did i started gaming
you know eric griffin gaming check me
out uh i haven't have a
couple of videos up with on my youtube
with ron and i playing yeah so i started
doing that and i just started like
reinventing myself i guess
finding ways to different how we can
monetize our personality
because i don't know about you but i was
super depressed at first because it was
just like we were
performing you know i don't know how
often you performed but you know we're
performing like two three four times a
week
in la then we go out of town or whatever
we were doing or we're working on a set
or whatever it is
and that's consistent it's part of our
life it's who we are or we thought
that's what
thought that's who we were then
this thing hit and it got all taken away
so you're sitting there like
how do i express these emotions how do i
get out this
energy that i have all the time and it
was tough at first how was it for you
yeah it's depressing that was the thing
i tell
my wife we get into discussions about it
it was hard for her to even understand
at first but then she started to get it
was just that because you know you know
we were fine find you know worry
financially for a couple months but
things started to handle out
and once i was still like okay i'm
acting i'm doing the voice acting but i
just can't do stand-up but that's how
i've defined myself
yes as a stand-up this is the thing that
i've
used to say if i've had a good day or
bad day and then based off of my sets
yeah when that was gone i was like oh
i've kind of just lost
what i feel like you know and i love
being a dad i love all these things
but you know selfishly i'm like this is
my purpose yeah to be on stage
selling these jokes and thinking in a
way like it was the best
lesson i ever learned to be like oh
that's so limiting
to be like oh this is what i am yeah
that's all i am it's like no there's so
many other
things you can and you could be so many
other things too it's not even just like
you are
other things what you realize is you can
become many things
you know i know exactly what you're
saying i had this kind of epiphany
myself going through the process
just being like super depressed also
thinking worried about finances too i
mean
you know when you're not one of the top
five percent comics who like
they already got millions of dollars in
the bank and whatever the thing is and
they're just doing stand up for fun and
to like get their legacy
it's different for like a person like
myself where like whatever money i'm
making on a weekend
we're even if it's a nice chunk of money
we still live in paycheck to paycheck
you know even though it's a nice
paycheck and then you both then you like
change your lifestyle
you know like the outcast song if you
don't move your feet
then i don't eat and we like neck to
neck cause you got to say you living
from that song the song from
from i mean even whether
you know people see you on shows and
stuff and they see that but it's like no
i'm going
i even you know that's been one of my
biggest lessons is being open to my wife
about stuff like that yeah
like money me like like oh like oh no
i'll tell you like this is exactly
how much this deal is and then now let
me
break down the ten percent here the two
years in here the ten
five percent here yeah the tax taxes
yeah
look at that [ __ ] kindred spirits
right here boy
and not even just that not even just
that is what you're thinking is
that this is also the retirement plan
you know what i mean
it's like wait what happened here just
lots of earbuds wait
wait what's up guys hope you enjoyed the
episode so far so right now i just want
to take some time to tell you about
our great sponsor of the show better
help
you gotta go to betterhelphelp.com
griffin
to get a discount on their service uh
better help it's about therapy you know
online therapy
uh you know there's so many things in
our life to interfere with our happiness
we've been dealing with this pandemic
for a year now we're trying to get our
lives back to normal
and that could be stressful we've dealt
with a lot of things this year and
better helped better help is uh the
online therapy that you need
i personally recommend therapy it helps
you organize your thoughts and figure
out like
the origins of some of the feelings that
you might have you connect in a safe and
private online environment it's
so convenient i highly recommend it
you can start communicating in under 48
hours and it's more affordable than
traditional
offline counseling and financial aid is
also available that's a new thing i'm
hearing about right now so
the services available for clients
worldwide find the
particular expertise that you need
i mean you're dealing with depression
stress anxiety relationships if you're
having trouble sleeping if you're
dealing with some trauma in your life
you're dealing with anger you have lgbt
issues you have anything that you think
you want to be able to deal with and you
need to talk to a
certified professional counselor better
help is
uh the thing for you all right so
um so many people have been using
betterhelp that they're recruiting
additional counselors in all
50 states listen i want you to start
living a happier
life today as a listener you'll get 10
off your first month by visiting our
sponsor at betterhelp.com
griffin that's help dot com slash
griffin
join over one million people who have
taken charge of their mental health
that's betterhelphelp.com griffin
for 10 off your first month
totally worth it totally love better
health let's get back to the show
yeah so like what i'm saying is like we
um
this is like so so whatever the money is
you get from a show whatever it is like
that
a portion of this we have to think about
i got to put this away
because that's the retirement plan you
know the retirement plan for
entertainers is whatever money you make
now
has to last you for the rest of your
life yeah
so you know my girl is kind of a
princess you know she just
you know she don't necessarily
understand that part i don't think i
think a lot of people in regular society
don't understand like it's not easy for
us to buy a house even though they think
it is
it's not easy for you know because you
have to prove your income you have to
you know
yeah you know that's the thing yeah when
i bought my house it was the worst thing
basically my money history was like
okay uh two years ago i had
negative money yeah and now i got enough
to get this house today
yeah can we make this deal today yeah
because
in two years it might mean i mean
you know it's like it's funny that like
when you're going to buy a house you you
actually want to have a partner in your
life
that has a steady regular job because
it's going to
actually be on them which is this which
is a funny part about it you know it's
like but anyways
that's what so we're going through this
whole process which you know we're
defining ourselves as this and that and
and then yeah when you got somebody in
your life you got to kind of go okay hey
listen
let me explain to you how all this works
and it just it was like a whole big
thing about what's important and what's
not important
and i'm at a whole different place right
now you know engaged
now and just trying to re-prioritize
like who i am and what i do
and you know and then you know i'm still
doing the podcast and still doing
you know i started the gaming so that
became a job that i got to continue to
do and
you know but it's just like all these
different ways to do stuff like we did
that show together on
on the on the amazon that twitch show
that paid us
like i don't know why they paid us that
much money
[Laughter]
i think they're looking back on it like
why did we pay those people that
do much again
[Laughter]
for real dude for real dude it was like
why are we doing this you know
and so it's like we found all these
different ways to do it and so now
as the world is coming back i think
we're starting to look around and be
like no i don't necessarily have to do
it the way i did it before
no definitely i mean speaking of i had a
thing recently where i was getting ready
to go back on the road and but then i
had a
like a online gaming related thing
come up and they needed me that day and
it was the first time where i was like
oh i have to cancel this stand-up gig
because i have a gaming gig
that's more lucrative yeah straight up
like i'm i thought i think about i made
more money doing gaming
related things in the pandemic than i
did
in stand-up the year before so that made
me feel like okay
i'm not gonna go to such a such city now
for a certain certain amount unless it's
not even just about the compensation but
is this worth it yeah it's worth it is
it fun is it fun is it worth it is it
like you know
i mean just everybody out there no
matter what your job is i mean i'm sure
there's people out there with like
they're not working from home
and they might think to themselves well
why are we going back to the office
do i have to go to the office five days
a week i was just thinking about that
that mentioned it on the affirmations of
my podcast getting better with ron
punches all drop plugs in the middle of
things please do professional
uh i was just talking about the just the
very
idea of the 15 minute break is so
[ __ ] insulting
really how so because what the [ __ ] am i
gonna do in 15 minutes
yeah what am i supposed what amount of
relaxation am i supposed to get done in
fifth 15 minutes it'll probably take you
17 minutes just to wind your
brain down and get away from all the
nonsense that you were just dealing with
all day i know exactly how i went when i
had a job i remember working at the
grocery store it's been the first five
minutes talking [ __ ]
about whatever customer that pissed me
off before
i spent that next five picking out lunch
for later
and trying to text someone at home
making sure their home life was okay
and you spend that last five looking at
that clock wishing you had that other
minutes back
yeah it's not relaxing at all and just
the um
i think a lot of people i've been
talking to on twitch people who have
been working from home
who are now going back to work is this
that they're having a hard time now i
think like
it's just kind of thing like we were you
removed the veil for a while and now
you're trying to put
it back on yeah and people are like no i
can get the same amount of work done in
three hours
as i used to do coming here for eight
hours a day yeah and i don't have to
deal with
you you know what i mean that that
middle management piece of [ __ ]
that like that person who thinks gumming
up the worst yeah yeah yeah they have to
like you know be like they
make themselves feel important so
they're going to be all on you it's like
nah
i know i can one i don't got to get
dressed you know
so i could do this from home in a robe
oh you don't know how
much i was cursing you driving over here
yeah i know it's just you know
pocket it is a better atmosphere and
energy once i got here for sure
i made you a macho you know yeah that's
true it is delicious and buttery
and flavorful but not overly sweet it's
a perfect matcha yes honey
with oat milk
so it's healthy er too i love it i love
it
it's good so yeah i'm glad i know i know
what you're saying man about just
everything that we do like i don't know
have you you've worked on a set in the
past year right and during the thing
yeah i just got finished doing two
things and man i'm telling you these
these coveted you know restrictions
are just sometimes i just i don't get it
sometimes
yeah just and it's so funny though
because um
you could tell the safety ones are like
okay i get safety is fun but then
now it's also the ones where you really
like uh
like man you guys are just really
reinforcing this call sheet and this
guest star thing where you're like where
they're just like okay
because i'm doing the guest role i need
four masks go on
and don't touch the regular actor dude
it's so weird no my thing about it is
like to me it's just a dog and pony show
okay well he's like let's not get sued
it's a right
show up to the you know it's for optics
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah to me what they
should do is offer a waiver
they should say like cause because i
don't know about you but if i'm saying
yes to an acting job
i'm saying i'm totally fine with getting
covert or not getting coke
right i mean well i just i i think i
diverge from you there
but how though like it's like if you're
willing if you're saying i'm gonna go
work on a set
where we we got to be around a bunch of
people i think you're making that
agreement where you're saying like okay
this is a you have the chance because
we're not being socially distant we're
pretending like kova doesn't exist in
this universe of this movie or tv show
so we're saying that hey i'm okay
i i i i agree i'm okay with the risk i
think the risk is worth the reward
yeah well i think you're saying yeah i
mean i guess if you put it that way that
you're saying like i'm aware of
the risk i'm taking yes i'm aware of the
risk i'm taking and i'm okay with it
you i mean because they're so weird
because it doesn't make any sense to me
like you know
they have all these things red zone or
yellow zone all this [ __ ] you know like
group are you yeah what group
you have your mask on mask mask and then
everybody's getting the other people got
to shoot them
and then when they say action this comes
off so you think kovit is just like oh
they
they filming so let me just
let me let me just wait over here when
the red lights going right right right
the act like covert is going like this
oh this is such a good scene
let me wait for them to put their masks
on so to me i go
at that moment you don't care about
health and safety hollywood like don't
tell me that like
so the times we have our masks off on
safety safe to safety but we got to get
this shot so
so what i'm saying is like we have to
get tested two times every two days
uh most people are now when i say most
people i'm talking about the country i'm
talking about most people that are
working in the entertainment business
that i know have gone out of their way
to get vaccinated you know what i mean
because of this exact thing they want to
get back to work
so um okay so
i'm ready to go because it's
uncomfortable like
you when you have the mask on you you
feel it's a weird thing
yeah you don't have to act with the mask
you're rehearsing
there's something that you have to make
up on and all this kind of [ __ ] i know
it's first world problems okay i know
there's people out there
he's usually just cracking it's not like
i'm doing drama yeah yeah yeah yeah
even still though there's something
about being in a good mood so when
you're if i'm supposed to be the comic
relief in this thing well how can i do
this man i just did this uh
this ray romano movie you know it's
really great he's just italian family
yeah that's the you got scenes with ray
yeah
do what yes yeah yeah yeah but it's like
but i'm like the comic relief in a drama
in a
dramatic you know what i mean but like
the the guy the covic
gustavo i call them they're just on set
you know what i mean
you can't even breathe without them
tapping in your hey i need you
guys you know so they got like this guy
would show up out of nowhere
and so like and i we were starting to
get contentious you know
yeah well that thing says even that's
bigger than the
guy right to you that just takes you
probably back to school and that's the
nerd who was like teacher you forgot to
give us homework yeah yeah yeah yeah
oh no eric didn't do this and you're
just like
[ __ ] yeah i know you piece of [ __ ]
but at the end of when i rapped though i
went up to him when i was like yo man
i know you're just doing your job thank
you and you know what i mean it's just
just tough you know
and he got beef with the script super
fun yeah
oh don't even get me started have you
been on have you been on
sometimes you have a script supervisor
that's a complete nazi
and sometimes you have one that are just
more lacks but i've had both
and i just i just can't stand the person
that comes over hi
ron this is it's not really for me
they were looking at the the the replay
and
we need you to say the
tomato you said a tomato
you just go okay you know as hard as a
comic though
as like when you get like a script
especially if it's a comedy script it's
hard to not
put your stank on it right away that's
why you hired me but
but at the same time though i also do
recognize it whoever wrote this
has been working on this for like six
months two maybe even longer
and they have it ready to go to the
point where they're shooting and they
hear we coming talking about
you know what this would be funnier but
that's giving people a lot of
uh uh you you're really being like oh
they've been meticulously working on it
we've seen these scripts we go out for
the same role half the time you're like
did you finish the spell check on this
okay i'm with you on that all i'm saying
though is
i i now know sometimes it's okay to like
give them the first read yes how how
they put it on paper
just to be like oh i said it that way
and then you just go you know i got an
idea
yeah just don't [ __ ] all over them i
think that's the thing as
i learned early as a comedian because i
used to do that i used to
just couldn't hide it because it was
competitive yeah yeah you know so i'd
read a line and i go
and then i do you want to say it like
this you know i see a writer go
you know his head just droop oh wait
this is important to them you know uh
but yeah i mean i did the small scene a
couple scenes in the movie
myself recently and that was my like
true
gives me these highs like um like when i
first started stand up but when like
i do take a chance and i don't tell
because i feel like if you tell them
when you add you know nonetheless you
were
better as forgiveness than permission
you're like oh can i do this joe yeah
and then they're like
running it by four or five people but
yeah you get to it so then i'm always
just like okay
one scene and the next one i should do
something completely different and then
i did this one and then i heard this
group supervisor it was a great lady
i've worked with her before from
blackish a bunch of times so
she you know respects me and knew i
would do it anyway
uh but uh go offline and then they hear
her
laugh like that's when i'm like this is
the freaking best because you're
supposed to tell me i messed up
yeah but you're like no he that's so
[ __ ] that's funnier that's good
which is the whole job to me anyway i
don't like it when people get so
um my favorite type of people work with
are just collaborators problem solvers
not these people who are like
i have a vision you know even when i
write my own stuff
i i think maybe because i come from that
background i'd be like look like i have
an idea
but i want you because i believe you can
add to it you know like if i wasn't
getting you i want you
unless it's something like and i also
understand it's like there's some words
that you have to say
in this moment you could change each
other i have mine so you can like have
more space
oh that's better yeah oh okay yeah lots
of angles yeah
i got to get a better but if there's
like some word that
caught that this person is going to
respond to then you go okay i get this
but i know what you're saying sometimes
you just want to go off the
you know you just just our comedic
style i mean sometimes you just know
what the joke is
you know like i know what this joke is
and there are many words to say this
joke
yeah and so that's really what we're
like we're finding my character would
say it this way
yeah i know your destination and you you
chose the left and the right but what if
i just went this way yeah yeah but i
also like when a writer or like the
executive producer
comes to you immediately is like you
know we're not married to these words so
you like you know then you just kind of
you know that's when it's great but
sometimes you have these people that are
like oh we really
you know we want to get it like let's
get let's get on book the script you
know
and so you know it is what it is now
speaking of doing movies and stuff like
that let's even get to even
while you're here professional
uh so you you've been trying to get
beyond your podcast for like
this last year and it took uh i know it
was because of the thing
promoters to make it dude you would have
been on before it's just a pandemic
i don't you don't know what people's
comfortability uh is and you know you
know what i mean
and by the way you understand i hate
asking people to be on the podcast
when it's like you know it's just that's
why i've been doing so many solos now
just because i feel like it's just me i
can just do it i bring rachel on and we
talk stuff you know i go oh let me just
make it about me
you know because then it depends on who
the guest is for the the people like oh
yeah yeah you're trying to promote
yourself anyway yeah yeah yeah
so but you're in a new movie it's called
golden army or
arm that's nice they're going to hate
you
should we do it like should i edit it no
i really want you to keep this
it's the silver leg
super leg i believe you play prince
shark
so you downgraded the porpoise prince
yes
how about you tell me about the movie
it's called
golden arm gold i got it right yeah so
right
now it is a female arm
wrestling comedy and over-the-top style
comedy if you remember that arm
wrestling oh yeah yeah yeah
but it stars uh mary holland betsy
sedero eugene cordero
myself uh aparna nancharla
a lot of wonderful people and it's just
a great comedy i play
carl who owns and operates the arm
wrestling tournament and is a lover
and purveyor and pusher of strong
beautiful women
all right that sounds like how a pimp
would say it but
a little bit i'm making something
you just you dress that up nice but
all right um well that's great you know
um is it
is it in theaters or it's on it's online
it's both in theaters and on demand so
if you comfortable with going out
i do encourage that it's a great
experience i went back to the theaters
for the first time recently
saw mortal kombat with my son oh great
so you were
thoroughly disappointed with that huh no
i see
but that's who you are that's who you
are what did you want
that's why you want shakespeare what did
you want no no i'm not no no see how
come it got to be that extreme
i don't necessarily want shakespeare but
i want something that's like
better than that you know what i mean i
thought it was great i liked it let's go
blow the full blow on it what you didn't
like
okay the first i like the first 15
minutes of the movie
because i cuz i love that sort of like i
love that sort of asian kung fu
stuff like any time it's like you know
it's the the stoic
dad who is like they're this like
warrior who's
semi-retired type of thing the new black
samurai
anime on netflix no i haven't seen that
watch the first two episodes i was
getting my nails done today i'm about to
check that
out i like to do that too good for you
yeah you got a person yeah
i go to this yeah okay yeah you got
somebody oh natasha she's great
her name's natasha at noir nails but
everybody go see so shannon sharp jaleel
white
me oh it's like that yeah so it made me
feel good
you got to be one of those people that
they if they if they if there's like
something on
you know something on the bravo channel
where they you know where they go like
oh
hair nails are the stars you're like
that this person will be on there is
that kind of thing
yes okay great all right well i might
you know let me get the hook up
um yeah so that's what i liked about the
at the beginning of the movie but then
it just got
ridiculous when it went into modern
times and this guy
who like i just don't get god okay we
can agree there i don't know who this
guy
is why he wearing a wicker basket yeah
what's happening he got no powers he
didn't look like a good fighter
at all he got his ass beat by regular
little people yeah so how is he all of a
sudden a mortal kombat person
didn't seem like it was gonna happen to
me i talked about this on bobby's pocket
i wanted to do
did bad friends like a guest host and i
was saying about this like this dragon
tattoo
if you just have a random dragon tattoo
on you
you're not gonna just like oh well
but that's the world the mortal kombat
you do play mortal kombat 11
yeah yeah i don't like it you don't like
mortal kombat 11
no dude because when you play online
those
eight-year-olds on there with their
little fingers are you
it's not fun they're really good i can't
have any [ __ ] because i'm not playing
rachel's not playing mortal kombat
yeah well but but it's just i i wish i
could get my money back
that was a waste of ninety nine dollars
however much great game you're
completely wrong
but you got i think that okay if you
look at the movie as it's like kohl's
movie it's a bad movie but that's like
looking at community through
joel mckel's lens when it's not it's too
that bad
the movie is the battle between sub-zero
and scorpions listen
i'm with you all of that listen um like
i enjoyed godzilla
you know it's a great movie i enjoyed
that movie because it's just like yeah
no this is mortal kombat's no godzilla
versus carl okay but it's in the same
it's in the same genre of like we're not
looking for shakespeare i just want to
have a good entertaining time and see
some fighting
you know you i gotta say kung fu fixes
let's not lie we both probably love
godzilla versus kong because he's got a
chubby
black male lead and you're when i see a
funny chubby black male lead in the
movie
my first thought is how come i didn't go
out for this
that's always my first thought then the
second thought is like well good
yes because that means that means they
reaching forward
that means a few years from now when
he's too busy
listen i'm always i'm always okay with
like like if i'm
like you know you can understand this
language
where you are on the call sheet okay i'm
always gonna be between like
four and nine you know what i mean
depending on how many cast members there
are
and occasionally we might get lucky
where we're getting like that sitcom
where we're the fat
dude and then in the skinny wife and
it's like that's our
whatever it might be and where we get
lucky and get a deuce bigelow type of
thing
ace ventura or whatever the you know and
even not even that because he was so
you know but i'm just saying like you
know so i know how it is to be
right in the pocket there and i'm gonna
i'm gonna be the best friend to the hot
guy
i feel like you looking at yours you
telling yourself an old truth and the
new truth
is that's like you the you're the
uh you're the dad lead of a family
sitcom where you're over
overworked by all these kids that's what
i'm saying that
i know that's when we could be number
one on the call sheet i'm saying oh i
can't wait
yeah that's what i'm saying i know what
you mean exactly you know you need a
modern day cosby or something like that
you know what i mean
well you know what i mean so like like
we
everybody loved him and then we found
out all this [ __ ] yeah it's true so i
mean it's like we can't
but we also a lot of people knew about
that stuff i mean there was always the
rumors and the spanish
you know what i didn't see here now i
never heard anything like that i mean
it's just like because you know what the
thing is it's like
you know i come from an era where we
didn't have internet we'd our
information
was all the news or it was like
magazines and it was just like you know
gossip and we never really had the um
the the amount of information that's out
there right now crazy when you think
about it yeah could you imagine like
james brown if he had to live
through the internet age that guy was
going into places and shooting up bars
yeah yeah man
but how about this one babe ruth babe
ruth wouldn't be revered
if the media was the way they are now
babe ruth
was a fat drunk taking drugs you know
you know
but he was back then the press protected
their
stars they were like well we want to
revere this guy he's our guy
now they're looking for ways to take you
down so i don't know if any of the
people that were celebrities of our
childhood could have made it now i mean
they would have got cosby
before he even got on tv jordan jordan
would have been
a lot of trouble yeah i think he would
have been in trouble
i think even if you look at like the pre
like
like the top most famous famous famous
celebrities
like michael jackson if his life was
scrutinized
in the way that people's lives are
scrutinized now
i don't know if he would have become
michael jackson
you know i just don't know you know
oj all these kinds of people that who
knows what would have happened
i mean it's like the i think more truths
would have come out because like the
whole thing with michael jackson man
it's like
that all started pre-internet and it now
that it's in the internet age you can go
down a deep rabbit hole looking at
michael jackson stuff right
and so many um like lawyers
and press people who have been studying
this for like 20 years
are are totally on his side you know
what i mean
so you have people that believe all the
allegations and you have these people
who have been like actually studying it
and looking at the depositions and
reading all the facts and telling these
things about
and so you go man look how they're
delving into people's lives right now
with all this
i mean just recently the the case was
thrown out again
by the way oh yeah i forgot about that
yeah the guy the guy from the from the
hbo documentary
who said all these things about him that
um
the judge threw it out again this is a
frivolous lawsuit with no
merit you know this guy's this is like
his 13th attempt
you know so i mean anyways my point is i
don't know if with all that
this information that's out there it's
amazing that people can even reach the
fame that they reached
right now yeah but i think i mean i'd
rather
have people no i'd rather be like is
that guy a weirdo oh i know
than than being like i don't know but do
we know
even in this no you don't know that's
what i'm saying i mean
like i just saw this thing so justin
bieber got dreads in his hair okay
yeah all right so now people are talking
about cultural
like a fun lady on vacation
like when you take your teenage daughter
to cancun and she come back
she come back she's hanging with the
little kids in the neighborhood you know
and she come back like what happened
jamaican boyfriend now here's the thing
though man the funny thing about it is
people
talk about cultural appropriation i
looked it up because i just wanted to i
looked up
origins of dreadlocks you know what
celts dramatic germanic
tribes vikings they all wore dreadlocks
all those white yeah or you just like
that
indian dirty like those more like dirty
locks though right those aren't i don't
even know
i don't what i'm saying though is like
for people to like in this modern era to
like like to cancel people and attack
people for things
they don't even know history of [ __ ]
really like it's like oh yeah i see that
all the time
you see that every day where people
don't know what they're talking about
but they feel so righteous
they feel so righteous and so i'm
looking at this
they're getting on this kid about like
this kid that you made famous
oh he's an adult now you're your own man
now but i'm saying
they for now 10 years
you know you know i always say like when
he was like 15
when he was nine they told him he was
great when he was 10 they told me he was
great 11 12
and the whole time he was like i'm not
great come on after he gets to like 15
16 he was like maybe i'm great
17. oh i think i'm pretty good hey susie
turned 18 he was like i'm great they
were like whoa whoa whoa
[Laughter]
whoa buddy we got to slow you down a
little bit here so it's like they
build them up to tear them down to build
them back up to tear them down so
i don't know yeah it's like another
outcast out you just if you wanna know
all about life just listen to the whole
outcast discography listen to that song
the whole world
that's what that song is about oh wow
yeah you deep into the hip-hop
references i like it yeah well you know
i
said outcast was better than the beatles
and then some people got mad and then
andre 3000 sent me some art that he
signed for me
and so that made me feel amazing oh wow
you said outcast was better than the
beatles yeah that's interesting
and truthful i think that the beatles
impact
is better than outkast i'd like to go
we're talking about to dig deep into
this again
let's do it you know more a lot about
the beatles but i know a lot about okay
see i i know enough to know that we're
still talking about the beatles
i think in 50 years they won't be
talking about outcasts
oh really that's why tell why because
outcasts
we could go down full lineage of so many
things that they've done
and i can go a little bit point for a
point you could go beatles people talk
about beatlemania
but the things coming over from the uk
into america
the people going into the uk sound but
they didn't really pull it but you get
more of the with the ramones some other
things you don't pull many other bands
out of the uk
right besides the beatles right that's
what i'm saying that's what i'm saying
we're talking musically just the
musicality of like the two different
things
i might agree with you in terms of like
you know but no i'm even going to go i'm
going to go
impact-wise is that you go then if you
look at outcasts they created their own
type of beatles mania in
atlanta and the fact that if you go back
into the southern palestine cadillac
music and their source awards went in 96
you go back in new york and everybody's
booing the crap
out of them because back then they
didn't want to listen to anybody from
the south
they didn't want to listen to anyone
that wasn't from new york or from los
angeles if you were from anywhere else
you couldn't have a career
and now the entire rap industry is
based out of atlanta and that's because
of the work of people
not just outcasts people like jermaine
dupri things like that oh yeah yeah but
outcast was the big reason why now
every every big rap album comes from the
south now
and that's that's their own version of
beatles mania they have their own
lineage as well you know after i
understand what you're saying but i
think it like i
i was on josh adam meyer's podcast about
he has this countdown of the top
500 albums of all time and and i got
into a big debate with him because i
said
well beta's are the original boy band
they're the first boy band
and he totally disagreed with me he's
like they're not a boy band i was like
yes they are a boy band and just because
they because people have this
perception that because boy bands don't
play their own instruments they don't
write their own music
that's not true freaking the the what is
it
um bop kids they they played every
single instrument wrote every single
song
you know what i mean justin timberlake
writes songs when he was you know some
of the backstreet boys
wrote songs they did i mean just you
know they this that
mania but also i think that
song for song i think that the beatles
catalog
is gonna be you know you you mean it
could be those catalogs pretty extensive
man
it is but you know hey jude come on man
hey
imagine hey y'all okay there's one
for every one for every one of our songs
beatles got probably two or three
of equal of equal like wow that was a
big song
i think we could go make a verses we
could do a verses
beatles versus outcast i can go jam for
jam for jam for jam
with the beatles and by the time but did
the bg's make a
outcast movie i don't know why i was in
the outcast movie
okay all right nobody saw that but i get
you
i didn't see the i didn't see the
beatles movie
sergeant pepper's lonely heart clubbing
no well that's old
that's 80s man that's what i'm talking
about times are changing outcasts
is the new best band times have changed
but we're talking about
the beatles have been relevant now
for what 50 years
i mean 60 years they're relevant sure
like what i'm so i'm saying
i'm not trying to buy a new beetle's
album
there could be no new beatles album
because they're all dead practically
exactly another point
outcast oh you're giving them a point
for being alive
yes
yeah i mean that is a big take it's a
big take for you to like
just outright say out so
that outcast career catalog music
influence you think is greater than the
beatles
i think of of if you look at
the effect of the modern era
if you go back and like oh of course the
beatles and this and that and you
couldn't
because people are going we even have
outcasts it wasn't for beetles like yeah
that's how technology works
that's how music works that's how
anything works but
also how that works is that things get
better
and i feel like that the outcast
has learned there's pop hits there's
deep lyrics there's
everything you want there's there's
songs that are being played
today that you forget like the last
outcast album was about 17 years ago
so and they're still playing hey yeah
they're still playing
roses they're still playing rosa parks
at stadiums when you go to basketball
games you know
that's cause those are the because
they're cheap to get
i don't think that's the reason i don't
think that's very i think because
those licensing fees are not as high i
think they got high
music well yeah well that's their fault
that's the beatles fault
for thinking that they're so beautiful
the beatles are like oh we're so great
you can't have our music like
well no no you know it's not the beatles
it's all the people that
bought like you know there's a whole
thing michael jackson bought half their
catalog
you know you know i mean and he you know
was using that i mean that's
that's how influential that was you know
he spent he made so much money off the
beatles catalog
i mean if you just go i think if you go
dollar for dollar it's probably not even
close
doritos sell billions of dollars
so you think beetles are doritos
so the beetles are doritos
caviar but if we're going to stay in the
chip world they take off
they salsa leader you're the only
[ __ ] eating sausalitos that's
the problem
you're just you're just an obscure
you're an obscure chip eater that's all
that is the best chip though it's the
most flavorful
chip this is like a ketchup sriracha
argument
yeah yeah right yeah i get it but i mean
catch you you can't
it depends on where you're at where you
at
i mean i'm not gonna lie all day long
i've been listening to outcasts to think
about this argument i didn't listen to
any beatles to have a counterpoint
but i listened to a lot of out well you
gotta be like listen
i'm not gonna go musicality for
musicality i'm not gonna go
talent for town to win you wouldn't
worry because you you can argue either
way i mean
you know i mean um john i mean john
lennon
the dude was you know he was a great
songwriter performer
paul mccartney he's still relevant today
he tours
you know what i mean so i mean they got
i mean they they were i mean
you can't deny that influential
of course not you know and and and the
thing too though in our society
um a white star okay
has a greater reach from that era
because you know like i'm sure there are
i'm sure there are white people in
middle america who you could play an
outcast song and they couldn't tell you
that that's outcast but i bet most black
people
could hear a beatles song ago is that
the beatles
[Laughter]
that's my point that was my entire point
of making that argument when i went on
twitter
and i don't like that i'm sick of that i
think that's the next
yeah um to me that's the next post of
dealing with
like systematic racism sit late and
uh prejudice is to not um
respect and and re you know revere
other culture to to fact you know the
whole black excellence thing is like the
fact that you have to be
excellent to be worth something yes i
know exactly what you mean
yeah as if as if it's like you know so
you have to be like the best of the best
to be like you know whereas like they
let mediocre white [ __ ] go
like all the time all the time like you
know just look at tv you know what i
mean like just like boom
you know it's like i know exactly what
you're saying it's like i feel like i
mean and i don't even think it's
it's conscious but i even feel it like
when i pitch my projects working my
project it's always just
fine i mean it's what we talked about
fine tubes on five two comb and then
i'll read an audition
from some like just you know some
well-to-do
white director or white writer and it's
like
oh this is rough like and this was okay
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's a weird thing
but at the same time though to play
devil's advocate on that because
i i have two problems with what you're
talking about not what you're saying i'm
saying but
just in agreement with what you're
talking about is that you know
to me not enough black dollars are spent
on black stuff
that's for sure you know so like there's
enough black wealth
in the country to actually make a big
huge difference and influence because
black culture still has a super large
influence on
young white kids it has the biggest
influence i mean that's the
we talk about time music you take
fashion
you know yeah the biggest like hits
where there's
fat and this is a probably a wild take
for people don't think but if you
know truthful stuff i think eric you
won't think it's well at all but most of
the big hits we see
of these things are like black culture
are and to be honest black culture or
gay culture
that they didn't water down and put
through the viewpoint through a white
male or a white female
and then they go boom we got it you know
yeah that happens
so much yeah yeah yeah and i get sick of
that to me because that's just like
i mean that's what i talk about i just
want um i wanted to
i talk about that all the time where
like you grow up and thinking this is
just kind of this
uh white normalcy of being like i'm
supposed to know
the bee gees i'm supposed to know the
beatles i'm supposed but you don't need
to know how green you don't need
they know it in this peripheral like
it's like it's it's like there but they
just go oh
yeah i know that you know i know but you
know i i
i remember back in the day
buddy see we grew up in an era now where
you know we look at tv i watched
seinfeld
i watched seinfeld because it was
hilarious but i also watched martin
you know what i mean i also watch so but
there are people who like the things i
watched
today yeah but i had a buddy of mine he
was white and i remember him saying to
me he was like hey i didn't
i don't watch he was talking about some
black shows he was just like well you
know
i don't get it i don't relate to it or
whatever
so it's as it is as if he couldn't find
the humor in it
because he he felt well this is only
funny to black people then right
and it's like we you know as
minorities we never had the luxury to do
that
like seinfeld is one of the most um
like specific culturally point of view
of the most like
you you're that's another like that's
exactly a perfect example of it is like
how many black people or of people all
cultures know so many
jewish things because they watched
seinfeld yeah yeah yeah yeah you know
and that was okay and that's fine and it
is okay it is fine i want to learn about
that
that's one of the things that makes it
interesting that's what makes any show
that's what made workaholics amazing to
me is that
when you watched it you were like oh
this is a world they have their lingo
they have their point of view and i'm
being invited
into it yeah no matter whether it is
whether it's seinfeld workaholics
uh martin and we talk about martin i i
that's one of my
absolute favorites i think it's one of
the best sitcoms ever made just because
hey you have uh immense generational
talent in martin lawrence in his prime
right and it is a classic
sitcom structurally done
perfect just everything is like it could
be these could be i love lucy
episodes they could be whatever episodes
and it's done through the lens of a
black dude from detroit
and that was groundbreaking to have this
dude
basically doing like a 70s 80s tgif
sitcom
but with black characters and to me i
mean i do the same thing like my
my wife who's canadian so she has the
double thing of
she grew up in white right canadian yes
yes yes
but then you watch like you know i know
exactly what you're talking about it's
like you know i think when you're a
minority you
you find your lens is you know wider you
just because
you you end up having to look at all
these different things and then you like
you can appreciate it enjoy
so many different things because you
don't see enough of
your own thing there's not enough stuff
being made
uh you know by the way good stuff too by
the way too
like i'm not one of these people that's
just like i gotta watch this because
it's black yeah for sure
you know cause then it's just like it's
not good sometimes it's just not good or
it's not your cup of tea
you know what i mean but then you got
like you know who chris i think his name
is chris tilly
lily he's australian or he's from new
zea i'm not sure where he's from
this dude is like he reminds me of tracy
allman like
oh yeah yeah chris he might be
certifiably insane
just because of how he could do all
these different characters
you know what i mean but he got this
show jamae
you know catholic school girl that is my
jam
that's just so funny that this 40 year
old dude is pretending to be 15 year old
girl
and just like being like just you know
but that's through that guy's lens
and then also the cultural of like this
is how they are in australia
you know so i can watch that and be like
oh i can enjoy this
but this kind of stuff comes to america
and sometimes you know american people
like they
it's like it's as if we've been trained
that everything should be white
and this isn't a race discussion guys
i'm just telling you like we become
accustomed to like
like when we watch tv we think okay you
know
we when things because now we noticing
it you like watch tv and you can go like
oh
you can see all white characters you
know this is just a show but if you're
like this is all black
oh it's a black show yeah that's a
difference even
but to flip it the other way me my wife
will have this discussion where she's
like
she goes like you love seinfeld and it's
set in new york and they don't have
any black main characters but you won't
watch friends because it's said in new
york and it doesn't have any background
they go like well friends is more
aggressively white like
they're going out of their way to be
white yeah science at least you know
what it is a minor
i believe that these four people
wouldn't have a lot of black friends
[Laughter]
that's what it is like i don't believe
that this
this character of seinfeld george elaine
and kramer
they i believe their world is that's
their world
as opposed to these these friends people
it's like
nah you know some black people black
people go to coffee shops
you know what i mean it's like you know
becomes like a it's there is a
difference but then
we're just we're just talking about
semantics and stuff or we're talking
about like you know
artistic how things are presented and
like
as like i said as a minority you have to
look at things like that you you know we
don't
we can't just accept things but nowadays
when you like so now because of like
they're going overboard with everything
it's like you know let's diversify
everything to make you know
the woke people feel good that's
noticeable too
but at the same time pandering but but i
guess
you got to go through the pandering
phase so it becomes
okay for us because it's like when you
see when i watch a commercial and i see
like okay here's this black guy and this
like
asian woman or something right and you
kind of go what are they doing yeah
they're right there you know what
it's uh uh a couple
of if you will go by hollywood
commercials
there is not a single couple in the
world that is the same race
yeah yeah yeah
a black nowadays and that's not what
we're asking black woman and a white man
it's always yeah i think i think what
we're really asking for is like
like like how you're wording it is like
we want to just see things through the
lens
of whoever that is no matter who it is
it's like if they're white
then it's okay that they're white you
know like let's make like so i feel like
they're sometimes ruining people's white
stuff
because how many times have you gone out
for a role where i mean the ones where
we end up at the audition together
bro bro 100
you know what those are this is what
happens they in a room they write a
white sitcom
they just it's not that they it's not
that they're it just so happens that all
these characters are white they wrote
the white the guy's name is jimmy and
the girl's name is helen and they they
write this sitcom to get it done
and then when they go through the
process they start to go
this is all white y'all should audition
we want this character to be black
we want this character to be non-white
and then we come in
yep and we reading james
you know we're reading james and then
we're looking at this and we're like
he's white this guy's white just making
white
yeah from the way he talks he's white
the way he talks his experience whatever
this is
make him white see to me that's not
where the
[ __ ] should change not at that level to
me it should change at the
at the creation level where it's like
hey you know when you that's how you end
up with a show called black lady sketch
show
you know you want to talk about a lens
yeah they putting the [ __ ] in the name
like this is
just a black lady sketch show but you
often see that when you
see a show that like from the
perspective of
women like if it's a show about women
for women
they have a it's like you're you you're
sitting like you're a fly on the wall
you know you're learning something like
like insecure is like that i love
insecure
and i feel like i'm fly on the wall when
i watch that show i feel like oh i'm
watching these black women be black
women yeah even um if we go back before
that like sex in the city yeah yes
exactly sex in the city was like even
though it was all white
but still it's from the lens of these
white women
these privileged white women living in
new york dealing with
privileged white women problems i'm fine
with that
you know what i mean i'm fine with that
i'm not one of these people that's like
oh wow
what they don't have no black friends
probably not
and i'm okay with that but all i'm
saying is like let's also have the
for black girl show you know or the
mixed friends show or whatever it is
that you know can we
can you find a way can you white america
can you find a way to see yourself
within that with without just looking at
race because that's what people do like
when you talk about workaholics
so many kids come up to me and they're
like oh that was me and my friends
so they found something to relate i
think you could find something to relate
and that's why when the cosby show was
at its height that's what people were
related to they were like
oh it's just a dad a mom
i want a dad like that i want a mom like
that i wanna i had brothers and sisters
like that
we lived in a nice house and we we
struggled with different things it was
like
so it was able to transcend you know
just looking at race yeah so many things
do i mean
to me it's seeing um some of the newer
things like the things that
that were like super super white that
have now been
um kind of i guess if we're going to
talk about
cultural appropriation it goes both ways
and to me i like to
depend on how it's used if you're used
to just profit off of black culture
which we see all the time that's worth
but if you're showing respect to things
and you just love things and this is who
you
are then i don't have a problem with
that because to me it seems so fun like
i
listen to a lot of young dolph and key
glock and
a lot of their album art is just beavis
and butthead but as
as them like two black beavis and butt
head characters
and there's so much now of like young
black rappers
who identify through beavis and butthead
i don't you mean man i mean i just want
to see
you know i just i just want to see like
let's not pander
let's not like make white people feel
guilty about every [ __ ] thing they do
all the time it's not about that you
know
or like or like do you have to it's like
oh we're going to have the wonder years
and let's make it all black now
you know what i mean like they yeah
that's the kind of things they're doing
now they're going to be like let's go i
dream of genie but they're all black
it's a whole other conversation about
like they don't you know just
mining nostalgia instead of creating new
ip because
it's easier and you can't make new stars
and
it makes people's value easier to
control but then that just that gets me
off on a whole
yeah wow i can see that that's gonna be
that's gonna be
part part three of the podcast
with uh ron functions i didn't even say
who you are i was like welcome to the
podcast people
know me they know me from saturday night
live sketches they say my name
speaking of you see how elon musk is
gonna
yeah i heard about that you know to me i
feel like because trump's not in office
they need a crazy white guy
yeah they need a crazy white guy to talk
about because like they made snl
so much about trump that they should
send them a gift basket
they were winning emmys they were like
they they gotta have this kind of
resurgence
yeah now that he's gone i feel like
they're just like so how do we be
funny again without trump how do we be
um
shocking shocking and nice so they said
oh let's have this guy be on the thing
you ever watch the movie bullworth oh no
i sure have it
warren beatty becomes a politician then
he starts saying whatever he wants
oh i do remember that and i was like i
was wondering if trump trump watched
that movie
and that's what led to him doing what he
wanted to do
i i mean who knows man
i mean it took a whole it took a
community
of people to get trump in office yeah
for sure it wasn't just like you know
that's why i always say like don't call
the guy dumb he wasn't
you don't become president of the united
states being dumb you know you're a
savvy dude you you know you surround he
knows how to surround himself with like
you know say what what should we do you
know i was i always go back to
he had this uh rally after he was
elected
and he's talking to the crowd i wish i
could find the footage i'm sure it's on
youtube
but he's saying to him because right now
you look like you could host a
right-wing political talk show
i know right
i can't stand those ones one more swoop
in your hair and it's all anti-black you
know
here's what's wrong with my community
one of those like larry elder or
something like that talking about black
lives matter but they won't talk about
what's going on in
chiraq
by the way i have a point about making
about that but
just just about trump real quick is like
he's having this rally and he's saying
to them
you know my people told me to say
drain the swamp and i didn't like it at
first but they said i should say it
he's saying this to his followers
and he's basically revealing to them i
got you
like i'm playing a role too to get
to to get in power and it worked yeah
thank you for not being informed
yeah it's classic carney is a wrestler
with a lover of pro wrestling
that's you see a thousand times the guy
who goes like
oh guess what i know a secret they're
screwing you over
yeah but not me
i know man but i always but getting back
to what you were saying
you know i always like i i like
listening to conservative radio and
conservative tv i like listening to it
just because
it's more entertaining like you're
really gonna hear like some wild [ __ ]
you know or it's gonna make you like
either reinforce how you believe
make you think like i wonder maybe not
you know but
the other side is just so like there's
no real
point you know it's hard to listen to
liberal radio it's boring
yeah when they're trying to either uh
when people try to out
woke each other yeah yeah yeah yeah my
favorite things on twitter yeah people
are like
there it is and then they go and then
someone else goes oh you mean
but what about this isn't this you from
eight years ago
you know man like in the wok the
wokeness is just gonna like
i don't know man i i
i don't know i can't last i mean at a
certain point people are
sad people go too fast and just yeah
they're going
and they'll get through it i mean to me
it's a lot of positives and just you
know
individuality and accepting people's
individual nature
but to just be like so i mean i think
especially because we work in
communication
you know to be like you're coming up to
work
like you want me to do this and then
this and that and this is now bad even
but you're not taking my heart and my
tone
into right right like while always just
like i always say like when we're doing
comedies like please don't assume ill
intent
yeah like don't assume ill intent like
assume i'm coming from a you know this
place
i just feel like everything people say
online should have the words to me at
the end of it
yeah that's all yeah that's it because
then then you're fine
so it's like if i if they listen to you
and they say like ron funches is a
racist
that's not how they end it yeah no no to
me
yeah and then we can go oh okay well
that's how you feel
let me let me get my own opinion then
everybody can start to be like well
what's your opinion of it
but when people make these blanket
statements but you know that's just not
good i know
that from therapy me too
me too i get my boundary issues from
therapy
my own you know i i totally i
therapies you know better help
or my i i think i have to do a
commercial for better help for this
episode so this is
as we're talking about therapy better
help is a great example of
you know and and and now that their web
because they can't put the cat out of
the
can't put the cat back in the bag now in
terms of like online therapy
because like it wasn't covered by
insurance you know that before
yeah it wasn't they wouldn't they
wouldn't cover the insurance but then
the covet happened
and they were like they had to you can't
take that away now
you can't you can't be like oh okay we
have to make people go to offices now
not enough so that's going to stay
yeah i think i mean i in some ways i
prefer the online because i'm in my
um i feel more open because i'm in my
house
right laying on my couch well i
the first time i did it i didn't like it
it was because of my own thought i was
laying in my bed i had my computer on my
lap
then i started looking at emails and i
was like oh i can't do this yeah it was
stupid
that was all me that was on me but then
the next time i did it showed up to one
high out of my mind right
and she was like i don't know if we're
going to get anything done this week
so then after that what i did is i sat
on my couch and i put it on the
table and then i i simulated the i'm in
an office
and it turned out okay you know but i
guess well you know
i'm uh i guess let me finish by saying
like because what i was going to say
earlier was like i
i totally understand i've met a few like
supe like black conservatives what i'll
say or
at any time i've met a figure who was
like hard on black people
who's black right they come to like you
know you stop claiming racism stop you
know
get you and then you hear their story
and then i go oh i get why you feel this
way
because a lot of times it's like they
had a dad who was like
dealt jim crow and had to deal with like
some hardships and
and then that he he rose and then made
sure his family
and so they had this feeling like we
could all do it yeah you know that's the
thing right i mean that's the thing that
even i struggle with because i go like i
come from a very horrible place you know
where
um no money no
community college dropout negative
accounts
you know and stuff and then just being
like i will and single dad
you know and then like oh i did it but
then i was gonna
like i oh i don't forget where it's like
oh it's hard work
i am in some i have unique skill sets
that are valued
uh if i was just really good at uh
woodworking maybe it wouldn't have
worked out that way
yeah yeah yeah and then unless you
started a youtube channel
[Laughter]
yeah yeah so there's ways so it's
it's really just kind of remembering
that all experiences are not the same
experiences and there's value in
everybody's different struggle and like
so it's hard to like making these like
because people like to make these
blanket statements and it's like you
know
and that's where we we don't we don't
discuss things we don't
see different sides different points of
view you know life is nuanced man it's
luan we live in the gray area we don't
live in this sort of absolute that
people
that the social media provides it's all
absolutes on social media
and it's not really the case you know
and if you just sat down with somebody
you disagreed with
and actually just had a conversation
even if at the end of that conversation
you were like
i'm more further reinforced that i don't
agree with you
but you also could be you still come
from a place of like well i understand
where you're coming from and that's just
really what i wish
we would get more of yeah i think that's
one thing i like about you and your act
like this one
the more i've gotten to know you through
the years is like when you first see you
or
you watch your work or college or even
just for my first time i saw you on
stage you're like oh this guy's brash
and like cocky and he's talking about
women but he looks like that
so but then you like listen i listen
more to you and think and you're like
man he's got
you're so much more complex and um
thoughtful uh than a lot of people i
think give you credit for
and so it's that's the fun of it right
is finding it and being like oh this is
deeper pool than i thought it was
you know what really bothers me man if i
can like get something off my chest with
you you can't
so so when you you know it's like you're
doing jokes you write your jokes
i like making jokes about women
if if i was making jokes about the
animal world
okay and i was only making jokes about
horses all right
horses could be like yo man what's up
with the ducks
you go you got no drugs about ants why
are you picking on horses
then in that case you could be like yeah
i'm probably singling out horses
yo there's only two kinds of people
there's men and there's women and
there's this small percentage of people
who
not sure which one they are or they want
to be the other or the other okay
and the non-bi okay so that's a small
but for the most part
it's 49.999 man 49.99 women
so there's not a big pool
of people to talk about they're saying
so this is what they say about you
that you don't talk about men no no no
this is what i do
i'm saying you know what i'm saying i
know but what i'm talking about is like
when you when somebody says that when
they go oh man
that's like oh you hate women because
you make jokes about them it's like
no women are hilarious
yeah you know they're just so funny and
dealing with them
as a man dealing with having a woman in
your life and then or
just just in the peripheral just your
mom's funny your sisters are funny
your girlfriends are funny women you
work with are funny like the the
the differences in the interaction
that's just funny so it's like it's just
frustrating when you like you know
you're just like
who else am i gonna talk about it's
universal it's universal
[Laughter]
but you know what though as you say that
anytime somebody misunderstands you or
if enough people say
something about you it does make you go
into yourself
and be like all right well let me look
at these jokes let me look at this
material because
if i'm saying this and it's making
enough people think not what i want them
to think
yeah then that's on me yep that's how i
look at it absolutely
it's your job as a business person right
if
you put out a product and people are
telling you that your project
product is labeling you a certain way
you have to either
adjust or accept it yeah yeah yeah yeah
for sure i've done that
a lot of times you're like oh that's not
what i'm trying to say right right right
i've had that happen when somebody comes
to oh you said this like i had to say
that it was like
you're like well that's what you implied
anytime and then you go oh [ __ ] yeah
so sometimes i mean you know it sucks
when someone gives it to you the wrong
way and they come at you like a jerk but
yeah
well that's how they come at you yeah
that's what the internet is people
coming at you at a journal i've been
i've had some positive interactions
where people are like look i heard this
joke
i'm a fan of yours i normally i know
because i am a fan of yours i know
you're a good person
so i just wanted to explain this to you
how this came across to me
that was you know when people come at me
like that that almost pisses me off even
more
it's long-winded or it's like you know
because like
because you know what it's going to be
the same dumb
misunderstanding it's like i just had
this joke about uh
you know i i'm not like i don't like
being designated driver
i don't drink alcohol so people always
want me to be the designated driver
and i would say you know being a
designated driver is like taking care of
autistic kids
at the end of the night all right
if you have autistic kid in your life or
you know somebody you're gonna be an
advocate
go my step to me and be like that's
inappropriate
you and i go for me i go did you hear
what i'm saying
it's like have you taken care of
autistic kids because it's very similar
it's like yeah it's not a it's not a
knock on them it's not saying you know
you know what i mean but
it's like if you assume ill intent yeah
then it's like you
so when somebody comes long-winded at me
about that it's it's still where i go
ah [ __ ] you you know what i mean cause
it's like i don't you know you're you're
you're making something out of nothing
it's it's like my point it's like if you
can't understand that that's just a joke
then who are you yeah i mean to me you
know
it's like uh some jokes are for you some
jokes aren't for you right right right
you know my son
has autism and would i be like oh i love
that joke
probably not but would i be like oh i
[ __ ] hate right that's what i'm
saying
yeah you know what the thing is it's all
related to
everybody's own personal experience it's
all anecdotal absolutely you know
this just that's how we deal with kovit
too sometimes i'd be like ah cove is not
that serious cause they've never met
anyone or know anyone that's died in
their life
and the same on somebody it's just
anything cancer ms
every any of these things dementia for
me you know
yeah absolutely you know so dementia so
if i hear somebody talking about
dementia but see i talk about it on
stage because that's how i deal with
things
but if i heard somebody you know and i'd
be like it's gonna hit differently with
me
good or bad because of my own personal
experience yeah so
knowing that how can like why attack
someone and make them
[ __ ] like we want to remove everything
bad that you have to say about anything
and it's just go that's that that's you
being close-minded
yeah no i mean i've gone through that
personally the same thing with with
autism where i would i like it because
uh you know there's times where
things kind of just become zeitgeist for
things and they just start throwing and
i just noticed that people were
like using autistic as a punch line
instead of [ __ ] which is the word i
don't even like to use
but right i had noticed that they had
started to do that and so that would be
a thing i was like well you're just
being lazy
you're being lazy and you're just you
you think this word now is okay
right right so i had a problem with that
but i had to realize like oh
i have a problem with that i cannot like
it i can go up and make jokes about it
yeah i can make fun of them
right i have every right to do that but
i don't have a writer just be like
you shouldn't say that exactly it's all
you know
i've had this all different because i
it's to me it's a visual joke you know
what i mean
it's it's a you know so like even
another one
i i i said you know
i had this joke about vegan pizza
you know vegan pizza
is like a transvestite because from a
distance
you're like
what do we have here what's that
but when you take a bite you're like is
that dick
this might be dick you know so that's a
strong bit
it's a strong joke okay i i stand by it
yes
but of course of course i get that so of
course some woke piece of [ __ ]
is gonna walk up to me and be like oh
you know you're
it's like i'm not saying anything bad
about
being this is the thing where you start
to break down structure of language
it's like just so people get to a point
where if you say a thing
it means that you're saying something
bad about that thing
you know and it's like no i'm not saying
anything bad about that thing
um it's happened many times remember
like and then i think like in the
early 2000s late 90s if somehow it's
just saying mexican sounded bad yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and
so it's like we just have to find a way
that's where the wokeness has gone
astray it's gone too far because like if
you just say one thing
you say a word that's a buzzword and now
it becomes like you know and of course
there are certain words where you just
go all right you know you got like
you know [ __ ] and word f word
you have these words where you go maybe
these words should just be removed but
you can't remove them because they're
there but you know as a comic you just
go do i need to talk about this
yeah it's like do they need to make a
joke about it's like do they need to
make a joke about um
do they say do they need to make a movie
about hitler yeah you know
probably a fascinating interesting story
but is that necessary
seen it done it yeah you know what i
mean it's like so i get it unless you
got a brand spanking
angle yeah yeah leave it alone so it's
it's it's just a struggle as a performer
as a comic that you try to deal with you
know you really tried to like you know
but anyway
though yeah i like having them yeah me
too find new things and evolve and
yeah me too movement made us evolve find
a way to also still be a little [ __ ]
you know that's my thing too it's like i
want to be able to still
call you a a [ __ ]
you know and i want at the end of it i
want you to be like
okay not like wow so
that's the challenge of a comic is to
find a way to say the things you want to
say
and them understand you even if they
don't agree i know you're wrapping up
but i want to ask you one thing go ahead
go ahead
um because you think you're an
interesting person to talk about this
you probably a person who might have
strong viewpoint
um but like when the pronouns and people
use on twitter i'm all for
like using whatever pronouns you want me
to use and to
have me identify you however you see fit
especially as a father
of a son with autism who changes his
personality and his name every six
months i had to call him courage or
bart or doug or tommy pickles
i changed his name all the time so i'm
like well if you won't call me to call
you miss or ms or whatever
i got no problem with that however
recently
i seem like i noticed that it's another
thing
co-opting where i see a lot of like
straight white males being like i'm he
him i'm gonna be like yeah [ __ ]
we knew that i thought this was to help
differentiate for other people who were
trying to get away
from people thinking they were you and
now yo that sounds to me like it's
equivalent to
white lives matter yeah a little bit you
know it's like
but here my thing i always liken it to
when somebody turns muslim
you turn muslim you want to change your
name to you know
ron shabazz okay sounds cool i just go
okay
this my thing is this give me a second
to acclimate myself to it
that's all you know this is this is a
it's a new unusual thing all right and
we're trying to normalize it
it's going to take some of us a second
so if you come at me
and you've been ron since i've met you
and now you want to come tell me you're
now rowena
for a little while i might still be like
hey ron my bad
rowena i'm not a devil because of that
no i mean i have real life experience
with that i have
my uh uh niece who's now my nephew
right it takes a second yeah it takes a
second cause i still go back and i look
at old pictures and i go oh that's my
niece boob oh no actually right right
it's like okay cause it's not something
that we're
this is a newfangled thing that we're
trying to like deal with
so our my generation is way harder to
deal with
uh you know because now in the future
generations
it ain't gonna be a thing you know
gender reveal parties
they'll go away yeah blue and pink is
gonna go away
and when you're turned 21 you do gender
you just yeah and you just show your
stuff
yeah yeah yeah i am this whoa
didn't know it was that kind of party
you know so i totally i totally get
um what you're saying there it's just
again we just have to
i always say we just got to normalize
these things
so it's it's something that we don't
have to deal with anymore like
gay transgender you know the
pronoun all that stuff it just needs to
be normalized where it's not something
we have to think about or even care
about
you know and once we get to that you
know we we care so much about people's
race gender and sexual orientation so we
could put them in a box and make sure
that they can only say and do those
things
in that box but what we're learning is
like it's more fluid than that
and when that becomes normalized then we
i think we'll just be happier yeah i
absolutely agree when it's it's
less even a concern yeah
what am i supposed to call you what am i
supposed to do like to be just like all
right well
at the end of the day it's like i don't
care yes
ron that is my whole point i don't
care so like i think most of us
don't care it's like when you find out
someone's gay i'm just kind of like
who cares that should be the response
well somebody says hey did you hear that
so-and-so is gay
your response really should be sell
what i don't know why that's such a like
that is such a thing that people like
who
like they need to know everything about
everyone for what
for what you know how does that make you
feel better
and and if you feel better it means you
look down upon
the thing that you think that person is
yeah and that's why you feel that way so
we got to get rid of that got to know
myself
all right well this has been my buddy
ron funch's hanging out it turned into a
ted talk
well that's all this always happens on
my podcast this is just me i i don't
know why
i can't be fun like bad friends and
yeah yeah i can't be fun like that
i don't know why it's like too much
effort it's a lot of effort yeah
come up with bits down time and be like
we're gonna
do this we're gonna put bengay on our
boat yeah yeah
[ __ ] what happened to just talking can
we just talk but hey it is
it is what it is so and make sure you
guys check out it's in theaters and
streaming right now golden arm gold
it's always a good promo when it gets
you say it like a question
go see golden arm it's in theaters
and on demand myself betsy sedero mary
harlan
also please watch chopped 420 on
discovery plus it is the chopped
franchise
appetizer entree dessert mystery
ingredients
weed and hosted by me dope is great show
check it out yeah not yeah and you know
if you
went in the quibby did your show go
someplace else it's in a roku box
somewhere it's available good so you can
still find
lebron from that all right
in this podcast getting better getting
better make sure you check that out too
i got to come
do yours now haven't done it because we
scheduled it but then something happened
had to go out of town whatever it was
let's get that on the books but thank
you for being here guys uh make sure you
uh watch me i i stream
and i'll come over there stream air
griffin gaming check that out
twitch.tv run underscore function he's
online too we sometimes play
uh we only play one game so i switched
out well we can i can play other games
god
i do you just don't ever see me play
warzone every day for five to six hours
and i still book television shows in
cartoons
i'm not how many people out there hate
me like oh that's all you do is like nah
i'm still
you know i still i'm still out here i
love the balance i'm like everything my
mom
said was wrong yeah i'm making money i
got a wee
tv show and i get booked through video
games exactly [ __ ] y'all uh
but thanks for watching with griffin and
thank ron thanks for being here
and i will see you next week
you